Other question voted up 77 votes.
Australia is holding a plebiscite on whether to legalize gay marriage.
I'm against the yes campaign,
but only because it's backed by Cultural Marxists.
I'm curious to hear your views on gay marriage.
Well,
I would be against the two of it was backed by Cultural Marxists because it
isn't clear to me that,
um,
it will satisfy the ever increasing.
What would you call it?
Demand for an assault on traditional modes of being.
Now,
with regards to gay marriage specifically,
that's a really tough one for me because,
you know,
I can imagine
I can't do anything really other than spout platitudes about it.
I suppose unfortunately,
you know,
if,
if the marital vows are taken seriously,
then it seems to me that it's a means whereby gay people could be integrated
more thoroughly into standard society and that's probably a good thing.
And maybe that would decrease promiscuity,
which is a public health problem.
Um,
although obviously that's not limited to gay people.
although gay men tend to be more promiscuous than average,
probably because there's no women to bind them with regards to their sexual
activity.
Um,
the problem is,
is that it does seem to me to be part of a wedge.
And it isn't obvious to me that legalizing gay marriage has done anything to
decrease the demand that the radical left neo Marxists types are placing on
traditional society.
So,
um,
those are my views.
I know they're confused,
you know,
because I'm in favor of extending the bounds of traditional relationships to
people who wouldn't be involved in a traditional longterm relationship.
But I'm concerned about the undermining of traditional modes of being,
including marriage,
which you know,
has technically and,
and historically been a union between a man and a woman,
fundamentally for the purpose of raising children in a,
in a stable and,
and,
uh,
um,
an optimal and stable environment.
So,
and marriage has already taken a fair bit of damage over the last few decades.
You know,
poor people are increasingly less likely to be married,
and that's really not good for them as far as I'm concerned.